alright we got a little bit more to get
on with before we wrap this up we've
been going for over an hour already
Chris but it's good we've hit a lot of
topics important topics as free agency
approaches and other franchise tags that
have been applied and what I want to
talk about first is Shaq Barrett
Buccaneers number one because it keeps
him off the market and I think he'll
stay with Tampa Bay possibly playing
under the franchise tender but it also
means Jameis Winston with 5,000 109
passing yards but also 30 interceptions
last year hitting the open market so the
Buccaneers keeping their top defensive
player and possibly saying goodbye to
the quarterback they thought they were
building their future around
yeah well makes sense you know I think
the big thing with Shaq Barrett it was
no doubt the best player on their
defense last year you know jpp is a free
agent and damos ensues a free agent
you know so the they don't want to let
too many of their starting defensive
linemen walk out the door and you know
again I have a lot of people going on
this guy worth the franchise tag money
yes I do think he's worth the franchise
tag money you know he's a really really
good football player am I really sitting
here ready to say that he's a star no
I'd like to see another year but I think
he has star potential without a doubt
when you just look at the way he plays
the Senate race you go back to watch his
film in Denver he was phenomenal there I
just didn't get to you know play and be
a starter he was stuck in a tough
position there a little bit but I
totally understand them franchise
tagging it I think he's a guy's listen I
don't think it's gonna be 19 sacks a
year right I think this is maybe the
greatest year of his career but I do
look at them and go oh he's very capable
of consistently getting double-digit
sacks every year 10 12 13 14 sack
he is capable of that and you know
ultimately I didn't expect the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers the franchise that Games
Winston yeah I didn't either and and I'm
talking we'll see how it plays out I was
told a couple of weeks ago that there
are a couple of teams that didn't even
want to begin to think about kicking the
tires on Jameis Winston until they see
whether or not he'd be tagged because
from their perspective it was
inconceivable that the Buccaneers
wouldn't find a way to keep him if
that's true then there may be a market
for Jameis Winston but I
we'll believe it when I see it Chris and
look I like the positive but the
negative outweighs the positive in the
opinion of Bruce Arians and apparently
in the opinion of others well yeah
that's right I mean you know he's he's
scary but I'll say this much Mike
man has his name come up a lot to me
really ever since the NFL Combine to now
with certain coaches I've talked to
around football where they just go oh
man I'd love to get my hands on Jameis
Winston you know cuz all coaches think
they can fix a guy right and they see
the denial and they all think they can
get a get rid of the bad that you just
talked about there is a lot of people
who like we've talked about for the last
few years that watch Jameis Winston and
you watch a good game and you go that's
one of the five best quarterbacks in
football unfortunately the next week you
can play a game where you go
that's the 30th 30th best quarterback in
football and that's the issue there but
I do think they'll be somewhat of a
market for a guy like Jameis Winston and
I still think Tampa Bay is certainly in
the mix too but you know does the old
Johnnie Gruden out in the Oakland
Raiders bring out Jameis Winston I know
he always loved him coming out in the
draft and even this time visiting down
there and Tampa you know that I would
think there's going to be some play for
Jameis out there and ultimately I still
think there's a good chance he ends up
back in Tampa which I want to talk about
more but I'm not gonna go can I talk
about that more yeah let me say this
though about Winston
yeah and Tampa I mean and you mentioned
the no risk at no biskits mantra from
Bruce Arians earlier in relation to Tom
Brady how do you reconcile that with
Jameis Winston having 30 interceptions
and as I pointed out before when Carson
Palmer was with Bruce Arians the first
year and over 20 interceptions Peyton
Manning is a rookie with Bruce Arians as
his quarterbacks coach had us a record
number of interceptions the record still
stands for rookie interception so I look
I I agree with you there are coaches out
there inevitably and usually it comes up
when it comes to character flaws but
there are coaches who think that I know
how to fix a guy
and whether it's Jon Gruden or anyone
else there's gonna be quarterbacks
coaches who think I know how to fix this
guy
I know how to get him to not try to make
those superhuman plays we're all just
kind of blows up in his face and if we
can iron that out we've got ourselves an
all-pro quarterback yeah yes and you're
right I think there's a lot of coaches
that think they can that's just the way
they are but you know he he's a talented
talented guy when his game is on he just
doesn't seem to have that governor in
his brain like you always talked about
to go wait this plays over it's not
going to work
you know abort mission abort mission he
seems to be like no screw you I'm gonna
keep going screw you abort mission I'm
throwing this ball into quadruple
coverage why somebody's holding onto my
shoulder and then disaster his there's
this Tampa Bay situation we talked about
Brady and as I told you I know there's
real interest there and I'm not shocked
because I feel like the Glazer family
has looked for this type of guy to be
the quarterback of their franchise for a
long long time and I think they would
like that for all the reasons you talked
about marketability billboards whatever
it may be that would be huge for the
Buccaneers organization
I do think Phillip Rivers is very much
in the conversation down there in Tampa
too and I do think his style of play
does fit Bruce Arians I mean he's a know
me he is a no risk it no biscuit type
guy and will stand in the pocket the
other name that I hear in Tampa a lot
Mike and this is the point I want to
make is Teddy Bridgewater and Teddy
Bridgewater makes no sense to me in the
Tampa Bay offense with Bruce Arians
you know he's not an aggressive down the
field thrower that's not the way he
plays he's a little conservative he's
kind of Charlie checkdown ish as you've
heard me say to me when I hear the Teddy
Bridgewater thing I think okay rivers
might go maybe Brady goes if Teddy
Bridgewater comes then I think Winston
will also be there with Teddy
Bridgewater and Bridgewater will be that
fact up plan to a Jim Smith's I don't
know this but that to me would make
sense because you're not going to play
pay Teddy Bridgewater 25 30
million-dollar you're starting money
where I think if they bring him in
don't be able to go okay if we combine
Winston and Bridgewater together that'll
be like one starting high-end
quarterback in the NFL and it gives them
a fallback plan in case Jameis Winston
just is that all an interception bill
once again next year
and I agree with you on Bridgewater
possibly the Bucks even though I look it
may not be from a football standpoint
the best thing to do but my belief and
my understanding is that Bridgewater and
his camp are rooting for Tom Brady to
stay in New England in order to open up
spots for Bridgewater if he goes to
Tampa maybe no spots for Bridgewater
which tells me that the Patriots haven't
made overtures about Teddy Bridgewater
and we thought that that could be a
direction they would go but look I think
that Bruce Arians would look at Teddy
Bridgewater as I have a guy who will
play it safe it's easier to kind of wake
up a no-risk get no biscuit attitude and
a guy who's inclined to play it safe
than it is to take a guy who's all over
the place and try to teach him how to be
safe some of the time I that's that's a
really good point by you Mike and I I
agree with you you're right you know
Bruce Arians might look at and go I can
coach Teddy Bridgewater to be more
aggressive he we know just you and I
being around Bruce Arians he's got a
great way about him he's one of those
guys when we have an interview with them
I'm like where's my helmet I'll I'll go
strap it up and play for the guy right
now I mean so where he has a magical way
with how he communicates and especially
communicates with quarterbacks to where
yeah maybe he could bring that out of
Teddy Bridgewater and you know even at
the combine when we interviewed him he
made a lot of comments about how good
his defense with was and he thinks he
can win through his defense maybe Bruce
Arians in his old ages you know maybe
hold it just the way he coaches a little
bit to where he might be a little more
conservative on the offensive side of
the ball and let some of these young
talented defensive stars help him win
football games a little bit more often
yeah I agree with you completely and
it's gonna be fun to see how it all
plays out
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports